ja also die frage stellt sich uns im
das läuft jetzt die frage nach dem
gute ins gegenteil verkehrt das heißt es
scheinen für das böse und gut immer eine
bestimmt überlegungen nicht
und böser mensch da wie das widerspricht
überblick über die themen und das erste
umstände waren so schlecht so ungünstig
unserer macht steht will endlich das zu
in den usa ein elefant gehängt worden
vollen sie dafür verantwortlich wir
zu sprechen ich gebe diesen fehler
verhältnis von gut und böse auf also das
verschiedenen gründen auf die ich noch
berücksichtigen die ich eigentlich
seminar auch ein seminar verzichte und
den allermeisten ansichten heutzutage
tun und darf man sich fragen warum
realität zu verlangen die mehr ist als
müssen immer schauen wie sah es mit
dass das böse entstehen musste
mit einem ganz großen kran können sie
hat so ein bisschen was von dieser
genauer eingehen werde
wirken auch heute ein bisschen behandle
berücksichtigen sollte und das kann mir
sollte ich überhaupt das böse tun wenn
ihren willen aus der dahinter stand
verhältnis von gut und böse es überaus
auch intuitiv dass man so einfach nicht
überhaupt möglich oder sinnvoll über das
da interessiert uns die trägheit des
endlose wille sofern nicht irgendwann zu
platon und platin das sein des guten und
kontradiktorischen these aber es hat
mal googeln ja weil er irgendwie sein
gesellschaftlich oder auch
vorgeworfen werden also auch die
jetzt will ich ein bisschen diskutieren
komplex und das habe ich auch in der
willensbildung ist eine handlung
allein der handlung können wir nicht
ich doch klar sehen dass es das böse ist
wer totgetrampelt hat ich weiß den grund
bösen fichte sagt wenn wir böse handeln
böse zu philosophieren das ist eine ganz
dem mangel des bösen dass die antike
naturalistisch dass ein mensch so viele
einer handlung führt der anderen seite
menschen einfach auch diskriminiert oder
zusammenfassung schon herumgeschickt wir
das ist jetzt wie gesagt subjektiv das
gewissermaßen
noch was mit unserem willen zu tun da
das böse als böses tun da muss ich doch
nicht aber es liegt in uns ein bedürfnis
unbedingt ansehen ob sie gut oder böse
nur sehe ich eben nicht in den kopf
spannende frage
genauer gesagt stigmatisiert also häufig
ist eine aktivität drin das ist nicht
liegt bereits im begriff des willens
dann handelt in uns der schlendrian
philosophie dann geht es in die
thema diskutieren das ist meine ansicht
nachteile durch seine biologische natur
können dieses verhältnis auf
warum sollte man überhaupt über das böse
war wenn wir schon vorher zum beispiel
vielleicht kann man sich schon mal
andere anderen riesen manchmal sogar
muss man auch sehen dass sie auf die
nur logische relation sind da
spätantike
verschiedene weise verstehen man kann
einer anderen person ein ja um etwas zu
verrückt sein wenn ich das tun
könnten uns der fall vorstellen wo eine
durch seine sozialen umstände erlitten
gewinnt real als der schlendrian ist
augustinus der wille zum bösen da spielt
steht dahinter einfachen machtinteresse
und ich halte nicht zurück und es gibt
realisierung einer handlung gerichtet
philosophieren ist das böse nicht
unternehmen wir selbst eine relation da
sagen das ist liegt auf der hand dass es
person
warum sollte ich das tun warum nicht
bewerten objektiv muss ich eigentlich
eine person diffamieren dass man sie als
auch gegenständen
manipuliert wird von einem bösen
etwas was ja
andere ansichten wir werden das auch
hat dass er vielleicht gar nicht anders
eigentlich wieder tun und das nichts ein
ist allerdings hängen wir bei der
der wille eine rolle auf dem ich heute
so auf den ersten blick einleuchtend das
immer das gute tun das heißt diese
das böse zuzuschreiben obwohl es
ästhetischen erkenntnistheoretischen
treten wir in erscheinung durch unseren
wissenschaftler einer bösen
sehen bei platin und bei platon die
ganze böse nennt genauso gut diese
werden konnte als böse oder das ja nicht
auch schon eingegangen bin dann thomas
unkontrolliert ist was unkonzentriert
realisierung unserer handlung von
wissenschaftlerin des gehirn manipuliert
dritte perversion story titel hat auch
böse ist es logisch
zugang zu den jeweiligen handlungen
haben da andere auffassung als ich sie
willen da ordnen wir zb unsere
phänomen das ich den philosophischen
von aquin die theologie also die
anders konnte als an bösen willen zu
äußeren umständen ab die wir nicht immer
vielleicht gar nicht passend ist ja
viele probleme das heißt sie muss zeigen
wird so dass sie nur noch grausame taten
idealisierung die auch nicht an
ist etwas nachlässig ist dieses
kontradiktorische gegenteil das gute
jetzt bevorzuge aber so sollte es ja
zugriff entzieht warum sollte man nicht
warum kann ein tier nicht möglich ist
entwickeln oder böse zu handeln kann man
zweckmäßigkeit des gutes und der mangel
haben ja also das ist ein großes problem
wie wir dazu kommen das böse zu tun und
nachlässig diese trägheit so bestätigte
adäquates eine person grundweg als
privatinteressen das was wir uns als
vollbringt wenn wir das sehen in der
in unserer hand haben wir können uns
auch sein dafür also wie gegen eins
also ist
ihr nicht böse sein ja es scheint dazu
des bösen wir sehen hier wieder hier
natürlich auch die auffassung vertreten
einfach nur über das gute philosophieren
individuen betrifft dem
gegen dieses kontradiktorische
das böse und dann haben wir noch es mit
welt dass eine person das konto dann
etwa den fall denken wie ich meine böse
schlechthin als gut zu bezeichnen
dass ist diese umstände sind dann stellt
muss man sagen ja das wollen auch weiter
also das ist ein wenn aber das gute ist
gibt es einen bezug zur
verhältnis spricht dass einem solchen
oder
allgemeininteresse über wenn wir zum
handlung durch zufall und verblieb weil
denken wir tatsächlich sie verbringt
sich natürlich die frage ja was liegt
das wäre dann eine heilige person so war
notwendig zu sagen dass es frei ist dass
die wahrheit
hier wird dann das thema selbsttäuschung
hegel zu tun das wird dann sehr
verhältnissen tourismus zu grunde legt
spätantike der mangel wird bei platin
beispiel die these vertreten wollen dass
denn auch in der hand dieser person wenn
dann ist das böse nun einfach delegation
etwa umstände eintragen die diese
böse handlungen wenn wir aber wissen
es selbst entscheiden kann mutwillig das
kompliziert wir werden aber nur einen
warum gerade über so
diskutieren und ver 5 spricht dass wir
das allgemeininteresse das gute ist so
eine große rolle spielen also viele
er doch oder sie determiniert war setzen
ihr das normative verhältnis also das
es gibt sicherlich in bestimmten
handlungen letzter sekunde verunmöglicht
dass sie manipuliert wurde das gehirn zu
kontexten aber im alltag scheint das
davon ja das könnte man die kontraktion
kurzen text lesen wie gesagt das gute
und platon thematisch und er kommt auch
böse zu tun und ein elefant der seien
sprechen manche immanuel kants
philosophen vertreten die auffassung
was den wert betrifft bei der regatta
seltsame schattenbereich oder dunkle
wenn ich im falle des bösen immer voraus
manipuliert wurde dann würden wir das
haben wie sieht es aus mit einer person
uns immer in gewissen umständen
dass wir uns im bösen eben selbst
und böse sind ersten sich auch logisch
nicht mehr angemessen sie zahlen eine
noch hier bei thomas von der queen ein
werte seine wärterin tod trampe der mag
dass die person auch hätte anders
renata sind diese jeweiligen zeiten
nicht mehr behaupten wenn wir wüssten
kategorischer imperativ geht auch so ein
person als durch und durch gut zu
these nennen also das böse ist einfach
verstehen im sinne einer wissenschaft
die einen bösen willens entschluss
befinden dass diese determination these
bereiche unseres lebens
bisschen vor dann geht's weiter in die
was in ihrem kopf vorgeht oder warum das
belügen dass wir uns selbst was
bisschen in die richtung die
handeln können dass sie also frei waren
gefasst hat will heißt immer handlungs
es sicherlich auch getan haben aus
einer relation und die asymmetrie die
bezeichnen in unserer lebenswelt
ich glaube eben das böse ist ganz eng
verallgemeinert unserer maxime unseres
vormachen dass wir uns selbst täuschen
die logik eines großen systems und
die negation des guten vielleicht ist
vorgehen das heißt der handlung können
frühe neuzeit zur leibniz dem
ihre schaltungen ja das sind diese
zwischen gut und böse herrscht nicht
absicht sage ich jetzt mal aber nicht
wirksames wollen also nicht nur ein
verwandt mit dem irrtum und dem nichts
43 spricht für diese handlungsweise
und so könnte man dann erklären warum
aber diese umstände können uns eben auch
willst das ist das gute des
wir es nicht immer irgendwie anziehen
nationalistischen denke das böse in der
probleme und die möchte jetzt noch
dann auch natürlich logisch äquivalent
hannah arendt spricht von einer das
mehr bestimmen kann ich glaube eben
wunsch ich würde mir das gerne wünschen
müssen schon noch ein bisschen davor
häufig wird das böse auch reduziert auf
widerspruchsfrei vernünftige
wir im bösen glauben manchmal auch das
weil er irgendwie böses im schilde
diskutieren also gegen eins gegen diese
aktivitäts these spricht dass wir das
das gute die negation des bösen hat das
nicht immer zu gerechnet werden also
blicken das was im willen stattfindet
nicht dass diese bloße logische relation
aber auch dass und wäre ein wille
verallgemeinern unsere interessen also
besten aller möglichen welten davon
führte sondern weil er sich bedroht sein
haben sie sicherlich schon mal die
ein irrtum dass man sagt das böse hängt
konnektivitäts these spricht dass
gute oder böse vor allem an handlungen
banalität des bösen
gebildet hat der möchte diese absicht
ist ja austauschbar das wäre eine
gute zu tun wer böse handelt er meint
und vielleicht seine instinkte einfach
auch da wird es ganz schwierig das böse
spricht bleibt er sagt wir leben der
die frage meiner krankheit ist das gute
dingfest machen können er beide dadurch
kollektive person hinsichtlich ihrer
hier kann man sich jetzt fragen warum
mit dem irrtum zusammen und das böse
uns wirklich was über die normativität
kann sie ihren willen kontrolliert
möglichkeit des bösen so zu verstehen
auch wirklich entschieden in eine
in das vorgegeben haben oder sich
besten aller möglichen welten und
oder gut in den umständen das sehen ja
nicht selten dass er eigentlich genau
und das böse ist dasjenige was ich eben
sollte denn das böse banal sein das ist
für vier für diese volition ali these
handlungsweise und willensbildung nur
realität erhalten ja also das böse wird
hängt auch mit dem nichts zusammen oder
das richtige tun und deswegen verfolgte
dass böse könnte aber auch als eine
handlung überführen nehmen sie mal eine
dieses verhältnis ist sagt ja wenn ich
trotzdem gibt es in der besten aller
gereizt gefühlt hat jedenfalls scheint
schwer zu bestimmen sind nicht alle
mit den schein wir werden das dann heute
also ich habe hier ganz unten noch
doch völlig unsinnig und auch diese
nicht verallgemeinern lässt und so
möglichen welten das böse was ist da los
das böse auch so entschieden und lässt
spricht dass wir hier hier eindeutige
unter logische privat ion also beraubung
mitglieder sind gleichermaßen in die
person hat einen solchen wilden gefasst
manifest durch handlungen und handlungen
sage ist nicht b&b ist nicht da habe ich
es aus heutiger perspektive sehr seltsam
geschrieben dass gut und böse scheint am
nicht davon los weil eben verblendet ist
kritik hat hannah arendt damals bekommen
könnte man auch das verhältnis verstehen
noch bei platon und platin sehen dass
was ist der grund dafür spannende frage
sie möchte jetzt irgendetwas böses tun
kollektiven entscheidung eingebunden und
zuschreibung des guten bösen vornehmen
sind eben nicht dasselbe wie die person
übergang von wille und handlung
als sie gesagt hat adolf eichmann dieser
sein tiere zu bestrafen und in
dass wir im bösen das gute
des guten verstanden werden das ist die
ist die theodizee frage angesichts der
aber durch irgendwelche umstände
also person vollziehen handlungen aber
könnte da kann dieser fall
daher verantwortlich auch stellt sich
erde sie und eben in diesem sahin
beheimatet sein also da ist irgendwie
nicht eine normative
diese phänomene alles ein bisschen was
prävention ist asse das war einfach sagt
irgendetwas böses
vielleicht nicht vorkommt dass jemand
diese zentrale person im
die frage wie das verhältnis der
kommt es nicht zu der handlung wie
gefangen ist und dadurch sehr radikal
mächtigkeit allwissenheit als güte
unterstellen was anderes ist tiere
letztendlich nur benutzen das gute
sie stehen hinter handlungen aber sie
das böse zumindest sehe ich das aber da
zurechenbarkeit von kollektiven und
mit dem nichts zu tun haben ja aber wenn
bedeutung gesichert also dieses rein
nationalsozialismus der war doch
das böse ist jetzt nicht genau das
manipuliert wurde man könnte sich
würden sie dann über diese person
werden kann glaube dass das so eine
interessieren also damit mit
gottes wie kann es kommen dass dennoch
müssen wir noch genauer darüber
sind nicht unbedingt immer mit dieser
höchstens noch überlegen könnte
individuellen versionen geartet ist also
eigentlich banal oder das böse was er
urteilen ist diese person hat sie was
es das nichts ist wieso sich mit dem
logische bestimmen von gut und böse
benutzen für unsere eigenen interessen
diskutieren ok jetzt gebe ich noch einen
gegenteil des kontradiktorische
lösung ist dieses dritte problem
handlung identisch und personen können
eventuell auch dass der wille so
wenn sich ein staat überlegen oder eine
getan hat er war doch nur ein
nichts überhaupt beschäftigen das nicht
das böse vorfinden wie verträgt sich das
gegenteil von guten sondern es ist
gutes oder böses getan
mit reizen zu hantieren um sie zu
anzugehen aber auch darüber wird noch
scheint mir noch zu formal zu sein da
und unserer eigeninteressen dem guten
schreibtischtäter
auch verschiedene handlungen
gesellschaft
ist doch nicht ist doch langweilig kann
einfach nur weniger gut
manipuliert worden sein dass er nur das
wir bekommen sehr gar nicht mit das
verschiedene produktionen kennen lernt
wie hängt dann die verantwortlichkeit
verantworten gut und böse sie können
in büchern ist das jetzt wirklich
über ordnen also zum beispiel die
fehlt einfach diese angabe des wertes
mit der existenz gottes diese frage
man doch gar nichts dazu sagen so
trainieren wird zu konditionieren das
banalsten wir müssen wir die banalität
jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar
also beraubung legten alle da gibt es
heißt man spricht hier auch manchmal von
stellt leider sehr provokativen
dieses staates wie der
manchmal gut manche böse handel sei es
allgemeinheit nur nutzen um eben selbst
böse ist tja dann könnte man sagen das
kandidaten des guten und bösen eingehen
dieser wertigkeit das böse ist eben
einfach ist es nicht und das ist das
ist was anderes aber auch da würde man
des bösen verstehen ohne das böse oder
verantwortlichkeit der einzelnen
moralischen glück oder mag manches hängt
prominent dann kommen wir zwei 17 und
ziel des seminars über dieses nicht gehe
die selbst sind nicht gut oder böse
ein quantitatives verhältnis ja
man muss sich fragen wer oder was ist
nicht nur eine negation der negation ist
personen zusammen delegieren die
das unmoralische was damals passiert es
erfolg zu haben das wäre zum beispiel
sagen konditionierung ist nicht
dauerhafte sind ebenso in diesem moment
ist nicht der richtige wille weil der
eigentlich böse
immanuel kant einmal die vernunft des
eigentlich bestrafung oder
zu verharmlosen man hat ihr
vielleicht auch ein qualitatives feldes
wenn wir betrügen dass wir eben auf das
wille muss immer gebildet worden sein
einzelnen personen ihre verantwortung an
auch von den umständen ab ob die
oder nicht ende des bösen war es
sanktionierung da wird man nie
verharmlosung vorgeworfen ich glaube wir
doch an sich jetzt erstmal gar nichts
da man hier am tag an die daten
wie ihre handlungen sind und man könnte
von dieser person der wille kann nicht
aber es fehlt ihm einfach was da ist
guten im anerkannt sagt dass das gute
handlung wirklich dann zustande kommen
den staat oder an vertreterinnen und
problematisch ist weil ich sehr
heutzutage in den allermeisten fällen
können sie so interpretieren dass es
auch nur von den handlungen sprechen
vertrauen der allgemeinheit rechnen wir
kann oder ob nicht vielleicht noch in
äquivalent dann wieder so formulieren
von einer anderen person gebildet worden
einfach ein defekt dana und ein defekt
gesammelt kollektive personen
herauszufinden immer natürlich auch mit
vertreter also irgendwie repräsentativ
gerade nicht verharmlosung bedeutet
sehr eng mit unserer vernunft
sagen da ist irgendetwas böses im spiel
gegen drei spricht dass dann eine
sein das musste eine kontrolle
setzen das vertrauen der allgemeinheit
kann das gut ist die negation des bösen
blick auf das gute das betrifft dann
letzter sekunde größere umstände diese
zusammenhängt er sagt dann aber auch
diese banalität des bösen möchte ich mit
und wird versuchen zu belohnen und zu
starten und gemeinschaften das wäre die
ganz spannende frage spannendes thema
voraus nur dann können wir betrügen der
handlung nicht direkt ansehen kann ob
bedingungen herrschen könnte man
ist jetzt ja nicht das gegenteil des das
also da kommt mir ein bisschen diese
ihnen diskutieren und abschließend
bestrafen aber ihrem sinne der
auch gleich die frage nach dem
noch dass das böse mit der vernunft
handlung verunmöglicht haben darüber
kollektivität these ich diskutiert die
sie gut oder böse ist es ein
könnte man zum beispiel auch nach hause
betrug setzt das vertrauen voraus wenn
diskutieren
konditionierung
befassen wir uns mit philipp armut eine
zusammenhängt das heißt wir müssen
verhältnis von gut und böse wir könnten
systemisches problem erkenntnis
das ist ein heißer kandidat
weil es nicht überlegen darüber zu
negativität diese normativität der
logische gegenteil nicht die logische
müssen wir diskutieren wie sieht es in
einzelnen kandidaten noch ein bisschen
handlungen ist ein weiterer kandidat für
theoretisches problem wir können uns
solchen fällen aus jedenfalls liegt
schauen was für eine rationalität wir
uns niemand vertrauen würde könnten wir
kontraktion hat dass privates verhältnis
schreiben aber ein sehr anspruchsvolles
neuere englische denkerin die
gegen vier spricht gegen die volition
genauer
sagen dass wir immer schon dazu neigen
dieses beispiel um irgendetwas böses
negativität zu kurz für zwei also für
einfach vorstellen will ich eine person
thema also kollektives handeln aus
das gute und böse ich nenne es jetzt mal
sind guten enthalten dass das gute
können sie nicht über die logische
individuelle personen oder menschen das
gar nicht betrügen dann gäbe es gar
gesagt hat das gute ist natürlich gut es
philosophisch am guten und an der
a den tod einer person b auf grausame
die aktivitäts these also das ist ein
ali these spricht dass ein bloßer guter
gute zusprechen muss wille und auch
nicht diese situation in der überhaupt
prävention
moralischer oder auch moralische
könnte man die personalie tc singen man
wahrheit orientiert zu sein und so die
irgendwie rationales können sie sich
rekonstruieren ja es ist einfach weniger
dieses diesen privates theorie spricht
betrug möglich ist betrug setzt immer
weise herbeiführt doch diesen grausamen
perspektiven
gibt etwas natürlich gutes
handlungen irgendwie zusammen kommen wir
wille noch nichts wirklich gutes
sofort denken es ist vernünftig dass
ganz heißer kandidat wir hatten hier
sein mangel eine kreation
voraus das vertrauen geschenkt werden
könnte natürlich auch sagen tiere sind
schattenseiten der philosophie aus dem
tod gar nicht intendiert hat es wie mir
brauchen irgendwie ein ergebnis an dem
gegen zwei gespräche in diese person etc
und es gibt dementsprechend auch ein
eine abstimmung gemacht die meisten von
gute zu tun warum weil wir alle davon
blick zu verlieren also häufig werden
dass damit diese normative asymmetrie
kann prinzipiell das heißt betrug als
böse also nichtmenschliche tiere es gab
dann gibt es noch eine dritte
hervorbringt von erich kästner kennen
wir das festmachen können sicherlich
ein versehen war
ihnen waren der auffassung oder viele
diese seiten gerne übersehen das was
profitieren am ende ist jeder profitiert
möglichkeit ich will damit nicht sagen
defekt an natürlichen defekt des bösen
so spricht dass wir dadurch menschen
können wir auch sagen diese person hat
ich will noch ein besseres beispiel
zwischen gut und böse berücksichtigt
form des bösen des moralischen setzt
im mittelalter und auch in anderen
dass das alle möglichkeiten sind es gibt
die hälfte ungefähr war der auffassung
unangenehm ist darüber spricht man nicht
sie vielleicht dieses programm es gibt
wird also dass das böse ist nie weniger
bringt totschlag im affekt oder
nichts gutes getan weil sie hat sich
wird zerstören nichts
zeiten vielleicht gibt es heute noch gab
dass handlung eigentlich das einzige
essenziell ist ish abstempeln und ihnen
die natur des guten müssen wir genauer
sicherlich noch ganz andere
immer schon das gute voraus das ist ganz
so gerne auch in der philosophie meine
aber wieso hat auch das böse eine
einen unmoralischen willen gebildet
nichts gutes außer man tut es
möglichkeiten das verhältnis von gut und
totschlag wenn eine person nicht recht
ja was weniger weniger sand sagt die
es prozesse und ihre verurteilt wurden
sind was gut oder böse genannt werden
die möglichkeit einer wandlung
diskutieren ja das sind die themen
interessant wir kommen da glaubt gleich
überzeugung ist aber dass wir uns
böse zu bestimmen das dritte wäre eine
allein die willensbildung kann ja auch
vernunft hat das böse überhaupt eine
kann und genauso viele vielleicht ein
absprechen können wenn man sagt diese
eigentlich nur dem guten und der
es hatte er das sie hatte ja einen guten
dafür dass sie einem menschen was getan
bei bewusstsein war wenn sie irgendwie
präventions- theorie ob das der fall ist
nach zu sprechen also wenn sie jetzt
als eine handlung angesehen werden ich
dieses seminares und ich beende jetzt
person ist böse dieser mensch ist böse
vernunft kann spricht auch von gründen
optionale also willentliche perversion
fragen haben dann können wir gleich
wahrheit annähern können über die
bisschen mehr noch unter ihnen waren der
haben ich glaube noch in den 50ern ist
willen aber
kann ja mal wieder bilden und ich kann
muss man diskutieren weil eben die
unzureichend war dann könnte man von der
auffassung dass der wille eigentlich
nachher darüber diskutieren wenn ich die
die zum bösen beitragen ganz spannende
jeweilige schattenseite also wir können
dann scheint man damit sie sagen diese
die auszeichnung damit wir dann in die
perversion jetzt im wörtlichen sinn eine
gut gemeint ist ist nicht so ist nicht
aufnahme beendet hatte das wäre so eine
faktische realität des bösen und auch
glaube ich nur dann wirklich auskunft
diskussion über gehen können
dasjenige ist was gut oder böse ist das
außenperspektive denken die person hat
frage man könnte ja sagen dass böses
person ist ebenso wesentlich und sie
interessante these und mein favorit sie
umkehrung oder verkehrung des guten das
seine zurechenbarkeit dadurch zu wenig
nenne ich jetzt mal die koalition ali
so gut wie gut gemacht ja also guter
über das gute bekommen wir verstehen
rational nicht weiter analysierbar ist
wirklich was ganz genau sagen das getan
kann gar nicht anders sein als so zu
these dann kann man auch nach sagen es
ahnen es schon aber ich möchte ihnen da
berücksichtigt wie jemand der böse
dass das böse ist und genauso nur
wille war da aber bringt alles nichts
hat sie auch aber sie ist nicht in dem
ist die perversion story also das wäre
sein als gut oder böse ein guter mensch
gar nicht vorweg greifen jeder von ihnen
völlig irrational diese these vertritt
handelt von dem würde man sicherlich
wenn die person nicht gut handelt wir
auskunft über die wahrheit wenn wir
gibt deterministische umstände die böse
soll sich hier sein eigenes bild des
die these das böse ist dasjenige was das
kann nicht und dann kommen auch fichte
sagen dass er oder sie in einem sehr
verstehen wie der irrtum funktioniert
bösen machen mein favorit ist hier
sind das nenne ich jetzt mal die
die hängen jedenfalls ganz eng damit
dieses dritte diese dritte these der aus
determinismus these auch da spricht
geringen gerade gut gehandelt hat oder
zusammen wir sollten ziemlich ausgrenzen
manches dafür was man könnte sagen die
eben gar nicht gut aber man würde doch
nicht heutzutage sagen dass er sie gar
nicht gehandelt hat oder dass das was er
oder sie getan hat weniger scientist als
das gute eine böse handlung ist
vielleicht sogar noch mehr sein als eine
gute handlung warum weil sie uns
vielmehr
betrifft sie sie verursacht vielleicht
viel mehr leid und dieses leid was sie
verursacht das ist doch durchaus seien
der oder also möchte ich ein wort zur
diskussion stellen häufig führt sogar
die these vertreten das böse ist
sichtbarer und irgendwie präsent
durch seine wirkung als das gut muss man
diskutieren
und vertreibt diese perversion story
spricht dass das böse wie das gute
unserer individuellen freiheit zu
gerechnet werden kann also wir sind das
willentlich die das gut oder böse tun
dagegen spricht dass dadurch nicht klar
wird warum wir uns gerade für das böse
entscheiden sollten wenn wir uns doch
genauso gut für das gute entscheiden
können also wenn gut und böse form
unserer freiheit sind wenn das so eine
art wahl situation ist wenn es eben in
[Musik]